[Música]
Olá,
minhas amigas, meus amigos. Seja muito
bem-vindos para mais uma live da
comunidade Estudos Avançados
do YouTube.
Muito bem,
hoje nós vamos falar de assuntos bem
interessantes, de estudos detalhados
e eu vou dar minha opinião clínica
baseada no que eu vejo também todos os
dias no consultório. OK?
Bem, são cinco tópicos que acabaram de
ser atualizados.
São assuntos que, na minha opinião,
ainda não estão recebendo atenção
devida.
Primeiro e mais importante, eu diria, um
assunto que poderia ser considerado
urgente é a questão do CBD e da
toxicidade hepática. Isso aqui precisa
entrar na cabeça de vocês, porque muita
gente tá usando o CBD de uma maneira
indiscriminada. Muitos estão comprando
no exterior sem orientação e
acompanhamento médico. E muita gente tá
achando que por ser natural o canabidiol
seria automaticamente seguro. E não é
assim, pessoal. E o nosso segundo tema
de hoje é a taurina e a sua relação com
longevidade. Nós temos um estudo muito
interessante da science que praticamente
passou despercebido pela mídia. Na
sequência vamos falar de creatina e
benefícios cognitivos. É um assunto que
eu já tinha falado antes, mas vamos nos
aprofundar disso aí.
E vamos falar de sucralose, né? Um
adoçante tão utilizado aí no dia a dia e
o que que ele faz com seu metabolismo, o
que que ele faz com a microbioma. Isso
pode incomodar muita gente que toma
todos os dias. E por fim, uma
atualização completa sobre colágeno,
separando o que realmente funciona do
que que é puro marketing. Então, pega o
seu café, pega a sua água, ajeita se na
cadeira ou na poltrona, a gente tem uma
hora aí de conteúdo denso pela frente.
Então, vamos começar pelo mais
importante, o mais urgente. E eu preciso
aqui ser muito claro, porque essa
informação pode literalmente salvar o
fígado de alguns de vocês ou de algum
conhecido que esteja utilizando o CBD de
maneira não apropriada.
CBD canabol virou uma vidira febre nos
últimos anos. Eu mesmo prescrevo com
bastante frequência, obviamente tomando
todos os cuidados e tem benefícios reais
documentados para ansiedade, para dor
crônica, paraa epilepsia e algumas
outras condições. Tá bem estabelecido na
literatura científica e nós que
prescrevemos estamos tendo bastante
experiência com uso, tá? O problema é a
banalização, como sempre, tem pessoas
utilizando o CBD, como se fosse um
remedinho qualquer, uma vitamina.
E isso não é correto. Vou aumentando a
dose, que não seria um problema se não
tivesse sem a acompanhamento. E vão
comprando produtos muitas vezes sem
controle de qualidade, misturando com
medicamentos, sem qualquer supervisão,
sem nenhum estudo de compatibilidade ou
de interação medicamentosa.
E a lógica por trás disso é sempre a
mesma que é natural. Então é seguro
lembrar pessoal que veneno de cobra
também é natural e mata, né?
Então deixa eu contar um caso que
aconteceu comigo há alguns meses. Uma
paciente de 52 anos chegou num
consultório, tinha elevação de enzimas
hepáticas. O TJ e TGP estava o dobro do
normal, não tinha histórico de hepatite,
não tinha histórico de bebê, não tinha
gordura no fígado documentado. Então nós
fomos fazer investigação e descobrimos
que estava associando várias coisas.
tava utilizando o CBD com doses altas,
sem fazer nenhum tipo de acompanhamento.
Então, ela foi aumentando a dose por
conta própria, porque não estava fazendo
o efeito e chegou a 150 mg por dia de um
produto de loja de produtos naturais e
não tinha nenhum laudo de qualidade.
Então, quando a gente suspendeu o CBD e
repetiu os exames em seis semanas,
obviamente entramos com si marina,
entramos com tocotrienol, com
alfalipôico,
com colina, as enzimas normalizaram
completamente, né? Então foi um caso de
hepatotorxicidade
induzida pelo CBD.
E aqui tá o dado que precisa ficar
gravado na cabeça de vocês. Doses acima
de 20 mg por kg de peso corporal por dia
estão consistentemente associados à
hepatotoxidade em estudos controlados.
Então, 20 mg por kg por dia é o limite
de risco. OK? de novo, repetir, 20 mg
por kg por dia. Então, para uma pessoa
de 70 kg, isso significaria 14400 mg por
dia. E é bastante coisa, né? Mas vocês
ficariam assustados com a quantidade de
pessoas que está usando doses altas,
especialmente para dor crônica ou para
condições oncológicas,
onde popularizou a ideia de que quanto
mais melhor. Mas o problema não para por
aí.
O estudo que mais me chamou atenção foi
publicado no Jaman, no Journal of the
American Medical Association, que é uma
revista bem respeitada e mostrou que
mesmo em doses mais baixas de apenas 5
mg por kilo dia, 5,6%
dos participantes apresentaram elevação
significativa de TGO e TGP. Então, as
enzimas hepáticas subiram e geralmente
quando sobe esses marcadores, isso aí é
significado de estresse no fígado. Nem
sempre, mas na mapada das vezes é isso
que acontece. Então, para uma pessoa de
70 kg, 5 mg por kg seriam 350 mg por
dia. É uma dose que muita gente pensa
que é moderada, mas para uma minoria das
pessoas 6% pode causar alteração no
fígado.
Então, deixa eu explicar o mecanismo
porque isso é importante para vocês
entenderem. Então o CBD ou canabidiol é
um inibidor do sistema enzimático
citocromo P450,
especificamente asoenzimas CIP 3A4 e o
CIP 2C19.
Então o citocomo P450 é responsável por
metabolizar a grande maioria dos
medicamentos que a gente usa. E o que
que significa isso na prática? que
praticamente qualquer medicamento que
você esteja tomando junto com o CBD em
dos moderadas a altas pode ter a
metabolização
alterada por competição.
Então a lista é grande, né? inclui
várias classes comuns, pode ser
anticoagulantes como vafarina,
aumentando o risco de sangramento,
antidepressivos como flocetina,
certralina, anticonvulsivantes como
valproato, ácido vappróico e a
caramazepina, benzodia azepínicos,
estatinas, bloqueadores de canal de
cálcio, alguns antibióticos e por aí
vai. Então, já vi paciente com o NR
muito aumentado, né, que é o marcador de
coagulação, porque tava tomando o CBD
junto com a vafarina. Então, já vi
paciente também com toxicidade de
antidepressivo porque a metabolização
foi bloqueada pelo CBD. Então, essas
interações são reais, tem que tomar
cuidado, podem ser potencialmente
sérias. Outro ponto que pouca a gente
sabe que o epidiox,
epidiolex,
que é o CBD farmacêutico que foi
aprovado pelo FDI para uso epilepsia,
tem um aviso de caixa preta sobre
hepatotoxicidade. OK? Então é a
advertência mais séria que o FJ coloca e
mesmo assim o pessoal acha que o CBD
comprado em loja de suplemento sem
controle de pureza e sem padronização,
não teria esse risco. Sim, tem esse
risco. Por isso que é importante o
acompanhamento laboratorial e médico.
E provavelmente esses produtos aí até de
ONGs brasileiras que não têm um controle
de qualidade muito rígido,
tem risco até maior, tá? Eu digo para
vocês, baseado em suposição, não baseado
em dados reais nesse caso. Então,
estudos de controle de qualidade de
produto CBD no mercado americano,
imagina que no Brasil que a regulação é
bem menor, mostram que uma proporção
significativa dos produtos tem
concentração diferente do que tá no
rótulo. Isso deve ser ainda pior no caso
das ONGs. contém contaminantes como
solventes residuais, pesticida, metal
pesado e às vezes tem THC não declarado
que pode agravar ainda mais o estresse
hepático. Então, qual que seria a dose
segura? Baseado no que nós temos de
evidência atual, doses abaixo de 10 mg
por kilo dia tem um perfil de segurança
mais aceitável pra maioria das pessoas
saudáveis. para uma pessoa de 70 kg, nós
estamos falando aqui de 700 até 700 mg
por dia, mas isso não significa que é
dose livre de vigilância.
Isso é bem importante. Se o paciente já
tem alguma outra condição hepática
prévia, gordura no fígado, né, chamada
da esteatose, hepatite viral, consumo
regular de álcool, uso de medicamentos
sabidamente patotóxicos, como o tilenol,
paracetamol, em doses altas ou mesmo o
uso do metatorexato, a vigilância
precisa ser muito mais rigorosa e as
doses muito mais conservadoras.
Na minha clínica, o protocolo que eu
sigo quando eu prescrevo o CBD é o
seguinte: primeiro vamos checar como
está o fígado. Exames de enzimas
hepáticas, vejamos como está a base
desse paciente antes de começar qualquer
tratamento. Depois a gente faz uma
varredura de todos os remédios também.
Essa pessoa tá usando, vê se tem que
suspender alguma coisa.
Aí a gente introduz o canabol, repete os
exames com quatro a sean de uso. Se as
enzimas subirem mais de duas vezes o
limite superior, eu reduzo a dose pela
metade ou suspendo, tá? E se a elevação
for maior que três vezes, tem que
suspender imediatamente.
Tem que fazer, então, como já disse, a
revisão completa de todos os
medicamentos para checar e também os
suplementos que podem ter aí uma
um impacto maior no fígado, né? O caso,
por exemplo, tem um suplemento que é bem
assim
eh pesado no fígado, tá? que é o a
espinheira, não espinheira santa não,
desculpa, é o é um que usa para
depressão.
Daqui a pouco eu lembro o nome dele, me
fugiu agora aqui.
Então, é importante orientar o paciente
sobre sinais de alerta, náusea, dor
abdominal superior direita, né, que pode
ser hepatite, urina escura, que pode ser
colúria, né, ou seja, eliminar aí
elementos e que geralmente não saem na
urina ou teríça que amarelou na pele.
Qualquer um desses sintomas tem queurar
atendimento imediato.
Então, sobre produtos, eu só prescrevo o
CBD de fabricantes que eu conheço bem,
né, que fornecem laudo de terceira parte
confirmando concentração, eh, se tem THC
ou se não, qual é o teor de THC. E isso
pode limitar as opções, aumentar o
custo, mas é o jeito que a gente tem
para fazer para ter segurança.
Então, resumindo, é uma ferramenta muito
interessante o CBD, eh, mesmo o extrato
de cannabis que tem a concentrações mais
altas de THC também é bem interessante,
tem vários benefícios documentados, mas
a gente tem que entender que isso é um
medicamento, não é inofensivo, a dose
importa muito, as interações
medicamentosas são frequentes e são
potencialmente mais sérias. Então, o
monitoramento da função hepática é é
obrigatório, não é opcional e é
importante
fazer o acompanhamento médico e o
paciente não pode sair aumentando a dose
por conta própria porque não sentiu
efeito imediato.
Bem, o segundo assunto de hoje, a
taurina e seu efeito na longevidade, um
estudo da Science publicado em 2023 que
quase ninguém comentou.
E isso é uma coisa muito interessante,
porque é um estudo bastante relevante,
que passou quase despercebido
e saindo numa das revistas mais
importantes em termos científicos do
mundo. Então o título do paper é Taurin
deficiency as a driver of aging, então
deficiência de taurina como motor do
envelhecimento. O grupo de pesquisa era
liderado por cientista da Columbia
University, que é uma das instituições
mais respeitadas do mundo em pesquisa
biomédica. Então, vamos falar da
metodologia que foi bem elegante e
convincente. Primeiro, eles documentaram
de forma sistemática que os níveis de
taurina no sangue caem
significativamente com a idade em
múltiplas espécies. No caso dos humanos,
uma pessoa com 60 anos tem em média
cerca de 1/3 da taurina circulante que
tinha aos 20, tá? 1/3, tá, pessoal? Isso
não é quedinha, é um colapso dos níveis
desse aminoácido.
Aí vem a pergunta crucial. Isso é apenas
correlação, tipo, você envelhece e a
taurina cai como consequência ou será
que é causalidade que a queda da taurina
contribui pro envelhecimento? Então, pra
gente poder responder isso, eh, nesse
estudo eles fizeram experimentos de
intervenção. Pegaram camundongos de meia
idade, que seria o equivalente a um ano
de 45 a 50 anos, dividiram em dois
grupos. Um grupo recebeu suplementação
de taurina na água, o outro grupo
recebeu água normal e acompanharam os
animais até a morte natural. E qual foi
o resultado? Os camundongos
suplementados com taurina viveram em
média de 10 a 12% mais do que os
controles. 10 a 12%. Em pesquisa de
longevidade, isso é um resultado muito
bom. Então, paraa comparação à restrição
calórica, né, que é tão falada, né, um
jejum intermitente, que há décadas
considerado padrão ouro de intervenção
paraa longividade nos modelos animais dá
resultados bem parecidos. Mas não foi só
o tempo de vida que melhorou. A
qualidade de vida durante o
envelhecimento também foi dramaticamente
melhor. Os animais suplementados
mantiveram menos gordura corporal,
preservaram mais a massa muscular,
tiveram melhor densidade de ossa,
apresentaram menos marcadores
inflamatórios no sangue, mostraram
melhor tolerância à glicose, ou seja,
melhor sensibilidade insulina, menos
resistência insulínica. Então,
basicamente, eles envelheceram mais
devagar em vários parâmetros. Então,
alguns dados específicos que foram
particularmente importantes. A força
muscular medida por teste pegada nesses
animais foi 20% maior no grupo taurina.
A densidade de óssea foi melhor e os
marcadores de senescência celular, ou
seja, os marcadores que indicam as
células que estão zumbis, né, células
velhas que não morrem, que não fazem
apoptose, esses marcadores estavam
reduzidos nesse grupo que tomou taurina.
E antes que vocês pensem, ah, mas isso é
coisa só de camundongo, né? Isso é uma
grande crítica que acontece quando se
faz isso tudo em cobaia e não consegue
transpor isso para humanos. Então, esse
grupo também olhou dados epidemiológicos
humanos. Em populações onde os níveis de
taurina no sangue eram mais altos, tinha
menor incidência diabetes tipo 2, tinha
menor prevalência de obesidade e
melhores marcadores de saúde
cardiovascular. Então isso não prova
causalidade, né? Pode ser só uma
correlação, mas é mais uma peça
interessante no nosso quebra-cabeça.
Então, como é que a taurina funciona? Os
mecanismos parecem ser múltiplos, estão
ainda sendo investigados, mas algumas
vias principais foram identificadas.
Primeiro, a taurina é um potente
antioxidante mitocondrial, então ela se
concentra nas mitocôndrias, protege as
roganelas do estresse oxidativo e como a
disfunção mitocondrial é um dos
marcadores do envelhecimento, esse
efeito é extremamente relevante.
Segundo, a taurina modula o cálcio
intracelular, que é crucial paraa função
muscular, cardíaca e neuronal, e com
envelhecimento, a homeostase de cálcio
fica comprometida e a taurina parece
ajudar a manter o equilíbrio.
Então, muito cálcio dentro da célula dá
problema, geralmente gera morte celular.
Terceiro, ela estabiliza membranas
celulares. Ela atua como ummólito. O que
que é isso? ajuda as células a manterem
o seu volume e integridade em situações
de estresse. Quarto ponto, isso é
particularmente interessante, ela parece
proteger o DNA mitocondrial dos danos
oxidativos. O DNA mitocondrial é muito
mais vulnerável a ataque do que o DNA
nuclear, porque é um DNA menos
protegido. Existe acúmulo de mutações,
que também se torna um dos motores no
envelhecimento. Então vamos à parte
prática que vocês querem saber. que
doses de utilizar. Então, os estudos e
humanos que mostraram benefícios
clínicos usaram doses na faixa de 1 a 6
g por dia. Tem uma faixa, eu sei, muito
ampla, mas isso reflete diferentes
contextos. Então, para efeitos gerais de
suporte ao envelhecimento saudável, a
recomendação do examin.com, que foi de
onde eu tirei essas informações da
taurina, é começar com 1 a 3 g por dia,
tá? uma dose padrão. Então você pode
estar tomando eh 2 g, 1 g de manhã, 1 g
à noite, é uma boa maneira de começar
isso. Ou 1,5 de manhã, 1,5 meoite.
Então, para pressão arterial, porque a
taurina ajuda a baixar a pressão
arterial, muito interessante nesse
sentido, existe um estudo mostrando que
1,5 g por dia divididos em três doses de
500 mg reduziu a pressão sistólica em 4
a 5 mg milím de mercúrio após algumas
semanas. Então, pode parecer pouco, mas
em termos populacionais uma redução de 4
a 5 mm de mercúrio na sistólica, na
pressão mais alta tem impacto
significativo em risco cardiovascular. E
para performance física, doses na faixa
de 3 a 6 g antes do exercício mostraram
benefícios em alguns estudos, mas os
resultados são menos consistentes.
Então, na prática clínica, eu tenho
usado taurina de forma mais sistemática
nos últimos 2 anos,
especialmente pacientes acima de 50. E
geralmente eu uso mais em pessoas
cardiopatas
e pessoas que têm problemas
neurológicos. Então, mas os perfis que
eu considero mais interessantes para
utilizar taurina, além desses dois que
eu acabei de falar, são pacientes com
fadiga crônica, pacientes tem
sarcopenia, ou seja, tem queda de massa
muscular ou fraqueza muscular. Pacientes
com perfil metabólico desfavorável são
pacientes com resistência insulínica,
né, pré-diabetes, síndrome metabólica e
pacientes vegetarianos ou veganos que
têm gestão dietética naturalmente mais
baixa. E a gente sabe que a tolerância é
muito boa. Em dois anos usando taurina
com dezenas de pacientes, eu não vi
nenhum tipo de efeito colateral
significativo. Tem de vez em quando um
relato de leve sonolência se a pessoa
toma uma dose alta de uma vez só de
manhã ou à noite. Mas isso é raro e pode
ser contornado eh distribuindo as doses.
Então, as fontes alimentares, se você
não quiser suplementar, as fontes
taurina mais comuns é carne vermelha,
aves, peixes, frutos do mar, ou seja,
carnes em geral de animais, né? Seja do
mundo aí dos mamíferos, das aves, ou
seja, dos peixes ou do mar. Então são as
fontes principais aí diatéticas de
taurina. Então isso mostra que os
vegetarianos, os veganos estão em
desvantagem porque eles praticamente não
consomem taurina na dieta, porque as
plantas têm concentrações desprezíveis.
Então por isso que o pessoal vegano e
vegetariano tem que ainda que pensar
mais sério ainda na suplementação.
Falando sobre uma curiosidade, as
bebidas energéticas têm a taurina, isso
gera muita confusão, né? né? O pessoal
faz muita confusão porque pensa que a
taurina é estimulante, eh, porque
associa o Red Bull. E o nome taurina vem
do latim Taurus, porque inicialmente foi
isolado na bil de Touro, por isso tem
esse nome taurina. E uma lata de Red
Bull ou de qualquer outro, né,
energético semelhante tem por volta de 1
g de taurina. E a taurina que eles
colocam no Red Bull não é para estimular
a pessoa, é para contrabalançar o efeito
da cafeína, tá?
H, então sobre time de suplementação,
eu prefiro que os pacientes tomem
dividido em duas ou três doses ao longo
do dia, longe das refeições principais,
é o ideal, porque aparentemente tem
melhor absorção assim, mas não é um
fator crítico. Se você tomar junto com o
alimento ainda vai ser absorvido.
Tataurina é um dos suplementos é que são
menos falados aí, é um dos menos eh
comentados e mais subestimados na
prática clínica. Ela é relativamente
barata, ela é segura e tem uma evidência
crescente de benefício sistêmico em
múltiplos órgãos. E já que estamos
falando aqui de taurina, vamos falar
agora da creatina e dos benefícios dela
além do músculo. Então eu falo disso há
bastante tempo. Já falei pra memória, já
falei pra cognição, já falei pro
contexto de performance física. A
creatina é provavelmente o suplemento
mais estudado e mais consistentemente
eficaz para ganha de massa e força
muscular. É muito utilizado aí
principalmente na musculação e nos
esportes competitivos. Tá tão bem
estabelecido isso que hoje não vamos
falar mais a respeito disso, mas vamos
falar mais a respeito é da evidência
para benefícios cognitivos da creatina
que tá ficando cada vez mais robusto.
Então vamos começar pelo básico. O
cérebro nós sabemos é um órgão
extremamente dependente de ATP, de
energia. consome cerca de 20% de todo o
ATP que o corpo produz, mesmo
representando 2% peso. Então, é um
consumo completamente proporcional que é
eh relacionado aí ao tamanho do cérebro
humano, que é desproporcional às outras
espécies.
E a creatina, como você sabem, ela é
fundamental pro sistema de fosfocreatina
que fosse uma bateria de ATP. É um
sistema que armazena ATP. Então, no
músculo, isso permite contrações
intensas. repetidas, porque a
fosfocatina vai regenerar o ATP, como eu
falei, como se fosse uma bateria externa
de celular e no cérebro permite a
função, a neural sustentada em condições
de alta demanda cognitiva.
Então aqui vem o dado que me convenceu a
prestar mais atenção na creatina uns
anos atrás. Uma metaálise que foi
publicada no experimental Gerontology,
desculpa, experimental gerontology, que
compilou resultados de múltiplos estudos
controlados e encontrou um tamanho de
efeito padronizado de 0,31 para memória
de curto prazo, com a suplementação da
creatina. Então, para quem não é
familiar com estatística, eu vou
contextualizar. Um tamanho de efeito de
0,2 é considerado pequeno, 05 médio e
0,8 é grande. Um 0,31 tá na transição de
pequeno para médio, mas é
estatisticamente significativo e
clinicamente percepível. Então é
comparável ao efeito de alguns
nootrópicos, como é o caso do piracetan.
Então é sim importante, é sim
interessante. Vai resolver sozinho
vários casos aí de défic cognitivo? Com
certeza não, mas é uma importante arma
no armamentário.
E vem aqui um ponto crucial, os
benefícios não são uniformes em toda a
população. Dois grupos específicos
parecem se beneficiar muito mais do que
a média. O grupo principal seria o dos
idosos.
Então a gente tem essa informação, faz
total sentido quando você entende
fisiologia. Então, com o envelhecimento
tem um declínio natural dos níveis de
fosfocreatina cerebral, a síntese do
organismo diminui, os transportadores
fincam menos eficientes, a suplementação
repõe esse déficit. Então, o estudo que
foi especificamente com idosos mostrou
melhoras em tarefas de memória de
trabalho, velocidade processamento
superior e tarefas que exigem raciocínio
complexo melhoraram após seis semanas de
suplementação.
Então, o cérebro envelhecido é
particularmente responsivo à creatina.
Segundo grupo que se beneficia mais são
os veganos e vegetarianos. Como a
creatina dietética vem quase que
exclusivamente da carne do peixe, mesma
mesmo caso da taurina, né? As plantas
têm quantidades presíveis, as pessoas
que não consomem esses alimentos tendem
a ter níveis basais de creatina
significativamente mais baixos, tanto no
músculo quanto no cérebro. Então, tem um
estudo interessante e elegante que foi
feito especificamente com vegetarianos.
Eles suplementaram 5 g de creatina por
dia por seis semanas e compararam com
placebo. Então, o grupo creatina teve
uma melhora significativa em teste de
memória de trabalho, de velocidade de
processamento e de fluência verbal.
Então, quando compararam a magnitude da
resposta com estudos em onívoros, usando
a mesma dose, a melhora dos vegetarianos
foi mais pronunciada, justamente porque
eles partiam de um baseline mais baixo.
Outro achado que tem implicação bem
interessante, bem prática, a creatina
parece ter efeito protetor em situações
de estresse metabólico cerebral. O
exemplo mais estudado é privação de
sono, né? Isso é muito interessante, que
eu tava vendo esse estudo umas semanas
atrás do pessoal que usa creatina de
manhã e glicina à noite. Então, existe
um estudo onde os participantes foram
submetidos a 24 horas sem dormir e
depois foram testados em tarefas
cognitivas. O grupo que tava
suplementando creatina anteriormente
teve queda muito menor de performance
comparada ao grupo placebo. Então a
creatina funcionou como um buffer, né,
como um tampão, mantendo a capacidade de
regenerar o ATP mesmo quando o cérebro
estava sob estresse.
Então existem muitas aplicações práticas
para isso. pessoas que trabalham em
turnos, né, pessoas que fazem plantão. É
o caso aí de médicos ou profissionais da
área de saúde, enfermeiros, enfermeiras,
eh pessoas que trabalham em plataforma
de petróleo, né, profissionais de turnos
noturnos, estudantes em épocas de prova
de concurso, viajantes frequentes que
lidam com jet. Então, seriam grupos
interessantes aí para utilizar a
creatina.
São situações onde a demanda cognitiva
pode ser alta e a qualidade do sono pode
estar comprometida. Então também tem
evidência emergente de benefício em
condições como traumatismo craniano leve
e concussão. Então a teoria que a
creatina ajuda a manter o metabolismo
energético cerebral durante a fase de
recuperação.
Alguns protocolos de atleta já
incorporam creatina após a concussão,
após bater a cabeça, embora isso ainda
não seja consenso. Então isso é muito
importante. por exemplo, caso aí do
futebol americano, né, que tem muita
concussão por conta aí do do estilo do
esporte.
H, dosagem para benefícios cognitivos. A
maioria dos estudos utilizam de 3 a 5 g
por dia. Então, a dose de 3 g é uma dose
meio padrão. É quando você compra
creatina como suplemento.
Aquela história da carga, né, que muita
gente faz, que quando começa a usar na
primeira semana usa 20 g ao diaidos,
isso não é necessário, OK? Então, para
efeito cerebral
pode começar direto com a dose de
manutenção de 3 a 5 g por dia e mantendo
indefinidamente.
E a maneira que você deve utilizar, a
forma que vale a pena é a creatina
monoidratada, tá? Não vale a pena
utilizar aquelas creatinas premium mais
caras, que seria a creatina HCL, a
creatina etiler,
ou ester, a creatina tamponada. não tem
vantagem nenhuma nessas creatinas mais
caras. Então é creatina monoidratada
mesmo. No Brasil é importante ou você
comprar de uma marca muito consolidada
ou com selo Creapuri, que é um selo de
qualidade.
Então só tomem esses cuidados aí com as
marcas e com o selo creapuri. Em termos
de efeitos colaterais, o estudo de longo
prazo são bem tranquilizadores.
A preocupação era sobre função renal, se
podia causar insuficiência renal. Isso
já foi derrubado. A creatina, ela
aumenta sim o marcador creatinina porque
ela é metabolizada, né? Os nomes são bem
parecidos inclusive, né? A creatina é
metabolizada em creatinina. Isso é um
marcador de função renal, mas pessoas
que têm função renal normal não tem
evidência de dano se você utilizar. Vai
subir um pouco a queratinina, mas não
quer dizer que tá ferrando o rim, OK?
Mesmo com uso prolongado por anos.
Agora, existe sim ainda a
contraindicação para não utilizar
creatina em pessoas que já t renal
diagnosticada.
Outra coisa que pode acontecer no começo
do uso é retenção hídrica, tá? A
creatina acaba puxando água pro músculo
ou pro intestício. Em doses mais altas,
é mais comum e isso estabiliza em torno
de uma duas semanas. E essa retenção
hídrica geralmente não causa problemas.
Então, na prática atual, na prática
clínica, pacientes acima de 55 a 60
anos, com queixa cognitiva leve, com
esquecimento, com nerva mental, com
dificuldade de concentração,
especialmente se for vegano ou
vegetariano ou baixo ingestão proteica,
por algum motivo, a creatina é bem
importante, entra no nosso arsenal.
Então, idosos, né, já falamos de
taurina, que os idosos têm muita
deficiência de taurina e agora nós
estamos falando de creatina. seria um
combo muito bom aí para idosos ou para
veganos, né? Então, usar aí de 1,5 a 5 g
de taurina e de 3 a 5 g de creatina por
dia.
E então a relação o custo benefício da
creatina é muito interessante. Nosso
terceiro assunto do dia é o uso da
sucralose, né? é um dos adoçantes
problemáticos. Aí ele não é
definitivamente um adoçante seguro.
Muita gente usa a sucralose todo dia no
café, nas bebidas. É um dos mais comuns
aí que você encontra supermercado. Tem
gente que usa associação de sucralose
com ah o stévia, achando que tá bafando,
porque pensa que o adoçante é só stévia,
porque os fabricantes escondem, né? Eles
colocam stévia na embalagem, mas deixam
o sucraló escondido ali no rótulo. Então
é importante que vocês entendam os
problemas da sucralose. Vamos trazer
aqui a evidência, né? E vocês decidem se
vocês querem continuar utilizando a
sucralose ou não, OK?
Marca americana esplenda, né? No Brasil
tem várias marcas
e é um adoçante já tem muitos anos no
mercado aí, eh, sendo divulgado como um
adoçante zero calorias, que não teria
nenhum impacto metabólico, porém a
história é bem mais complicada do que o
marketing sugere. Então, nós
recentemente tivemos acesso a uma
atualização sobre a página de adoçantes
artificiais e os dados sobre sucralose
são preocupantes e devemos prestar
atenção. Primeiro, o estudo que mais me
impressionou foi um ensaio clínico
randomizado, ou seja, um random mais
control trial,
ã, que é o padrão ouro de evidência. E
os participantes consumiram sucralose em
doses típicas de consumo normal por 30
dias e foram submetidos a testes
metabólicos antes e depois.
E que aconteceu? Após apenas um mês de
consumo, os participantes tiveram uma
redução de 20% na sensibilidade
insulina. Olha só, gente, eu tô falando
de uma doçante que não tem caloria, que
deveria fazer bem. Os participantes
tiveram uma redução de 20% na
sensibilidade insulina em apenas 30 dias
de uso, ou seja, já tá induzindo um
diabetes, apesar de não ter caloria.
Então, se você já tem algum grau de
resistência insulínica, pré-diabetes,
síndrometabólica,
e tá consumindo sucralose, pensando que
tá abafando, tá protegendo porque não
tem açúcar, você tá piorando o problema,
na verdade. E como é que é possível se a
sucralose não é absolvida entre aspas?
Então vamos falar aí sobre as respostas
que são fascinantes. Primeiro, a
premissa tá errada. A sucralose não é
100% não absorvida. Estudos
fármacocinéticos mostram que cerca de 15
a 20% da sucralose ingerida é de fato
absorvida pelo intestino.
Entra na circulação sistêmica e essa
fração absorvida pode ter efeitos
metabólicos diretos. Segundo mais
importante, a sucralose tem efeitos
profundos na microbiota intestinal. Essa
é a via mais preocupante. Estudos em
animais e confirmados em humanos mostram
que o consumo regular de sucralose
altera dramaticamente a composição das
bactérias intestinais.
Especificamente tem uma redução nas
populações de bactérias benéficas,
bifidobactérium e lactobacilos, né?
Então eles bagunçam a microbiota
intestinal.
e tem essa redução de até 50% nessas
dois nesse dois grupos de bactérias aí,
bifobactérium e lactobacilos. E o
problema é que essa alteração, essa
disbiose,
ela é persistente mesmo depois da pessoa
interromper o consumo. Infelizmente o
dano não é reversível de maneira rápida.
O mecanismo tá sendo intensamente
pesquisado, mas a principal hipótese é
que o microbioma alterado muda a
produção de metabólitos intestinais,
especialmente os ácidos grásos de cadeia
curta, é o caso do butirato, propionato
e acetato.
Esses metabolit eles modulam sinalização
metabólica sistêmica, incluindo a
sensibilidade insulina, a secreção do
hormônio GP1, né, o famoso GLP1 que tá
sendo tão falado aí por conta dos
remédios novos. para controle de
obesidade.
E também
acontece que esses metabólito também
eles modulam a inflamação de baixo grau.
Então é uma via indireta. A sucralose
não age diretamente na insulina, mas age
no intestino que comunica com
metabolismo sistêmico. Então o resultado
final é alteração metabólica real. Outro
ponto preocupante que poucas pessoas
conhecem quando a sucralose é aquecida a
temperaturas elevadas, quando você usa
para cozinhar ou assar, ela pode se
decompor e formar compostos de clorados
potencialmente tóxicos, especificamente
cloropropanois,
são classificados como carcinógenos,
OK? Então isso é uma coisa que eu até
aprendi na pós do lá em Ribeiro há sei
lá 8 anos atrás,
esse problema da sucralosea ser aquecida
e gerar esses compostos colorados. Então
isso foi demonstrado em estudos de
laboratório. Aquecer a sucralose acima
de 120ºC começa a gerar esses produtos
de degradação. E a indústria argumenta
que as concentrações formadas são
baixas, mas o ponto é que o perfil de
segurança muda quando você usa sucralose
em aplicações de alta temperatura.
Tem também a questão da resposta
cefálica. Quando você consome algo doce,
mesmo sem calorias, o corpo inicia uma
série de respostas preparatórias pro
metabolismo de glicose, pensando que
aquilo é açúcar. Isso inclui secreção
antecipada de insulina. Então essa
resposta, se ela for repetidamente
enganada, ou seja, doçura na boca sem
glicose no intestino, né? você engana o
intestino eh ao dar uma mensagem na boca
de que tem algo doce, mas que não tem
caloria, isso pode causar uma
desensibilização dos mecanismos
regulatórios ao longo do tempo. Então, o
que podemos fazer a respeito? Eu não sou
radical, eu não sou fundamentalista, mas
eu quero ajudar aqui vocês. Então, tomar
aí um refrigerante diet muito de vez em
quando, por exemplo, eh, uma vez por mês
ou duas vezes por mês, isso daí é
aceitável, tá? Hã,
o problema é quando você usa com muita
frequência,
quando você usa todos os dias, por
exemplo, tem gente que toma refrigerante
todo dia. Se você tomar três, quatro,
cinco porções por dia de alimentos,
bebidas adoçadas com sucralose, aí você
coloca sucralose no cafezinho, sucralose
no diet coke e sucralose no suco lá,
diet, isso vai te ferrando, tá? Por isso
tem tanta gente obesa hoje que piora a
situação quando começa a usar adoçantes
em grandes quantidades.
Então se você ou se os seus entes
queridos precisam de alguma doçante,
vamos usar stévia puro, pessoal. Esse é
o mais seguro, OK? Aquele produto que eu
recomendo meus pacientes, que é o stévia
da colorandina.
O stévia tem um perfil metabólico mais
neutro. Algumas pesquisas sugerem efeito
positivo na sensibilidade à insulina num
controle glicêmico. Só que temos que
estudar mais sobre o stévia, mas até
agora não apareceu nenhuma informação
negativa sobre esse adoçante, tá? O
eritritol ele faz parte da classe aí dos
álcools, né, dos poliois, né, o nome
mais científico. Você tem o erritol,
você tem o o por exemplo
eh chilitol.
Esse tipo de produto também tem
evidência que pode dar problema no
microbioma,
só que o problema que ele causa é menor
do que a sucralose.
E existe alguns estudos recentes também
que acho que foi no passado e foi 2023
que saiu, que eh esses produtos que
terminam em OL, né, os poliois tem
associações com eventos cardiovasculares
em pessoas de alto risco. Só que ainda
tá sendo discutido isso, ainda não é
conclusivo. Outro adoçante que a gente
recomenda muito no protocolo recode é o
bonk fruit, né, que é a fruta do monge,
só que é mais difícil de encontrar. É um
outro adoçante de origem natural que tem
um perfil mais seguro, só que tem menos
estudos, é menos conhecido que os os
adoçantes mais utilizados.
Na verdade, sendo honesto com vocês, o
mais tranquilo, o ideal é ir reduzindo a
necessidade de doce artificial de forma
geral, é retreinar o paladar. Esse
processo leva tempo, muitas vezes mais
de um mês, até 2, tr meses, para você
acostumar seu paladar a a não ter
açúcar. é factível e tem benefícios que
vão além de evitar os problemas dos
adoçantes.
Na prática clínica, quando eu vejo
pacientes com insulínica, pré-diabetes
ou cimetabólica e consomem grandes
quantidades aí de adoçante artificial,
eu sugiro um teste de fazer de quatro a
sean completamente sem ou substituindo
por alternativas como stévia.
a gente vê melhora nos marcadores
metabólicos e obviamente é um fator que
não é o único, mas contribui bastante.
Então nosso próximo assunto, antes de eu
ir próximo assunto, deixa eu ver quem
que tá acompanhando ao vivo.
Dra. Ana Paula, a Irma.
Tem uma pergunta da Irma aqui. Ótimo.
Que é uma pergunta relacionada aos temas
de hoje, né, doutor? A dose
de creatina pode ser de 5 g para uma
mulher de 50 kg? Pode, mas começa com
dose menor, começa com 2 g, tá?
Ah, mas o YouTube não vai mandar essa
placa não. Eles não me mandaram a placa
de 100.000,
Então eles não vão mandar a placa de 1
milhão não, infelizmente.
Pelo menos não tô esperando por isso.
Daí vamos continuar aqui.
Vamos falar do colágeno. Agora
é o assunto
é o último assunto de hoje. Acho que
sim.
Vamos primeiro separar
eh o joio do trigo, que o mercado tá
absolutamente tomado por marketing
agressivo e promessas exageradas.
Primeiro, a questão básica que dividiu a
comunidade científica por anos. O
colágeno ingerido oralmente chega aos
tecidos ou é completamente degradado em
aminoácidos no intestino e nunca é
reformado em colágeno no no corpo? Eu já
vi, por exemplo, eu vejo muito pouco
material dos outros médicos, mas uma
vez, por acaso, eu vi um vídeo do Victor
Sorrentino fazendo essa crítica, dizendo
que não adiantava tomar colágeno, porque
o colágeno ingerido não chegaria os
tecidos, porque ele é degradado em
aminoácidos e era reformado em outras
coisas. Então, a resposta baseada em
estudos mais recentes com marcação
isotópica, que ele não é 100% degradado
aminoácido do intestino, não. Tem vários
peptídios de colágeno, especificamente
de peptídeos e tripeptídios como
prolina, hidroxipolina e glicina,
prolina, hidróxipolina.
Então, esses peptídios de dois ou três
aminoácidos conseguem
se absorver dos intactos, aparece na
circulação sanguínea e parece ter
efeitos sinalizadores dos tecidos alvos.
Isso não significa que o colágeno oral é
milagre, significa que a premissa de que
a proteína oral não pode ter efeito
específico estava errada. Ou seja, o
Victor Sorrentino com a melhor das
intenções. Naquele momento ele não está
passando a informação correta, mas isso
já faz alguns anos, então ele não é
nenhum tipo de crítica ao colega, né? Só
comentei isso porque eu lembrei desse
assunto. Então os peptídeos bioativos
específicos do colágeno parece funcionar
como moléculas sinalizadoras. Eles vão
estimular os fibroblastos a produzirem
mais colágeno endógeno. Então, vale a
pena utilizar sim o colágeno. Quais são
as aplicações que nós temos evidências
aqui? E os dados são consistentes. Uma
metaanálise de 2019, ele compilou
resultados de 11 estudos randomizados
controlados com mais de 800
participantes. A conclusão que a
suplementação de colágeno hidrolizado
por 8 a 12 semanas melhora assim
fativamente a hidratação cutânea, a
elasticidade, a densidade do colágeno na
Dem e isso tudo medido por ultrassom.
Então, vale a pena sim fazer
experimentação com colágeno hidrolizado.
Esse é o colágeno que a gente chama de
verissol, né, que é o colágeno que é
mais apropriado para a pele.
Então, mesmo que eu tenha falado que
vale a pena, temos que levar em
consideração que os efeitos não são
milagrosos, são efeitos modestos, porém
são significativos em termos
estatísticos, são visualmente
perceptíveis paraa maioria das pessoas,
especialmente se você associar com ácido
hialurônico. Particularmente, parece
haver mais benefício em pele mais
envelhecida, provavelmente porque há
mais espaço para melhora. Em termos de
articulações que a gente usa o UC2, né,
o colágio hidrolizado tipo 2, aí a
evidência é mais misturada e depende do
tipo. Então, em dose de 40 mg por dia, o
C2 não hidrolizado,
ele funciona aparentemente por um
mecanismo diferente. Ele não é
nutricional, ele é um mecanismo
imunomodulador.
A ideia é que pequenas doses de colágeno
dois no intestino induzem tolerância
oral, reduzem a resposta autoimune
contra a cartilagem nas articulações.
Então é um mecanismo muito mais
intestinal interessante aí, né, do que
um mecanismo direto na junta. Então
alguns estudos mostram benefício em
osteoartrite por esse mecanismo, só que
os resultados não são uniformemente
positivos, tá?
Agora quando aumenta a dose do colágeno
hidrolizado, passa a usar 10 a 15 g por
dia. Aí já não é o C2, tá? Aí você teve
benefícios em alguns estudos em relação
à osteoartrite e dor articular em
atletas, né? Uma dose bem alta, de 10 a
15 g. O mecanismo aqui seria mais
nutricional, porque aí você tá
fornecendo uns aminoácidos específicos
para síntese de cartilagem. Só que aí,
eh, o que eu tô entendendo é que essa
quantidade aí de 10 a 15 g por dia,
parte vai parar na síntese cartilagem e
parte vai parar para outras coisas no
organismo. Os resultados nessa dose de
10 a 15 g por dia para doenças
osteoarticulares são menos consistentes
do que paraa pele. Quando a gente fala
de tendões e ligamentos, há alguma
evidência de que o colágeno pode ah dar
suporte à recuperação de lesões e
fortalecimento do tecido conectivo,
especialmente quando combinado com
vitamina C e consumido perto do
exercício. Os estudos em atletas mostram
resultados promissores, mas ainda não
tão conclusivos. Então, o que que não
tem evidência robusta? Usar colágeno
paraa perda de peso, para definição
muscular. para eliminar a celulite.
Esses daí não vão funcionar pelos
estudos atuais, tá? Então isso daí é
muito mais marketing do que realidade.
Não tem base científica para isso. Em
termos de dosagem pra pele, né, o verol,
o colágeno verisol hidrolizado,
você vai ter a maioria dos estudos
indicando de 2,5 a 10 g de colágeno
hidrolizado por dia. O
site que eu utilizo muito, que é o
examin.com,
sugere 5 g ponto de partida razoável.
Para articulações, doses na faixa de 10
a 15 g vão ser mais eficazes, tá? Então,
pele 2,5 a 10, articulação 10 a 15 g,
tá? Tem vários tipos de colágeno e tem
bastante marketing sobre colágeno, tipo
um, tipo dois, tipo três. Porém, na
prática, para suplementação oral, a
maioria dos benefícios demonstrados vem
do colágeno hidrolizado mesmo, o
verissol, que pode vir de diversas
fontes e contém mistura de tipos, não é
um tipo só específico. Pra osteoartrite
especificamente é muito divulgado o uso
do colágeno hidrolizado tipo dois não
desnaturado, em dose baixa, né, naquele
de 30 g, desculpa, de 30 mg que eu
comentei agora a pouco. Só que eh as
evidências mostram que é melhor até
utilizar doses mais altas.
Quais são as fontes do colágeno? bovino,
suino, marinho. Nos estudos comparativos
diretos, não parece ter diferença
significativa entre essas fontes. O
colágeno marinho ele é mais caro, tem
apelo de marketing, mas não tem
evidência que seja superior. Então não
vale a pena escolher o marinho, OK?
Escolha baseado no custo e na
preferência pessoal. É importante você
utilizar um colágeno que tem associação
aí com vitamina C, que é um cofator
essencial na síntese. Então é importante
você tá com a vitamina C associado e
também utilizar o ácido hialurônico
junto que vai otimizar os resultados.
Em termos de timing, não importa muito o
horário para efeitos de pele, pode ser
de manhã, pode ser de noite, pode ser
com, pode ser sem comida. Então aí o
importante a conveniência você não
esquecer de utilizar
para tecidos
conectivos, né, para casos de atletas
que querem ter efeito mais nessa parte
de tecido cognitivo,
há alguma evidência de que consumir de
30 a 60 minutos antes do treino junto
com a vitamina C pode ser interessante,
pode direcionar melhor pros tecidos
sendo estimulados. Na prática, eu uso o
colág hidrolizado, verisol, para
pacientes com queixa de pele seca, perda
de elasticidade, parte de um protocolo
antivelescimento com ácido hialurônico
para articulações, eu uso mais em
pacientes com ósteoartrite leve a
moderada ou atletas com dores
articulares.
E as doses já falei, né? Mas vamos falar
que uma dose típica de 5 a 10 g por dia,
pelo menos 3 meses para avaliar a
resposta adequada. OK? É importante ter
expectativas realistas, porque não é
mágica, é suporte nutricional.
Então, vamos falar aqui de sinergia e
combinações práticas.
Vamos dedicar alguns minutos aqui à
combinação de suplementos na prática.
Qual que é o melhor jeito da gente
estruturar um protocolo integrado?
Já falamos aqui sobre uma combinação que
é muito poderosa para pacientes idosos
ou veganos com queixas principalmente de
fraqueza, de folga mental, de neva
mental, queixa de queixa de fadiga
crônica, de energia baixa ou cognição,
taurina com creatina. Vale a pena até eh
usar os dois juntos no mesmo sachê. As
duas atuam em vírg complementares de
suporte energético celular. Taurina é um
excelente antioxidante, melhora a
resistência insulínica, né, como eu já
falei, e a creatina é uma verdadeira
bateria celular. Então, a taurina
protege as mitocôndrias do estresse
oxidativo e a creatina otimiza a
regeneração do ATP. É quase como se uma
cuidasse da fábrica de energia e a outra
garantisse que a linha de produção
funcionasse em capacidade máxima. Na
prática, 2 g de taurina dividido em duas
doses mais 3 a 5 g de creatina
monoidratada geralmente pela manhã.
Então você toma a creatina de manhã e a
taurina dividida em duas doses. Essa
combinação é particularmente
interessante para pacientes com fadiga
crônica, néva mental ou recuperação
lenta de exercício. E o custo é baixo.
Estamos falando de menos de R$ 50 por
mês pros dois, né? Vai depender também
da quantidade que você comprou. Ok?
Agora seria mais top ainda, se você tem
dificuldade com sono, você tomar a
creatina de manhã, a primeira dose da
taurina de manhã, à noite, a segunda
dose da taurina e à noite você toma
glicina 3 g. Aí isso vai ajudar mais
ainda no sono.
Segundo padrão que eu uso muito é o
colágeno, mas vitamina Cácido
hialurônico para pessoas que tm queixa
de pele e articulações. A vitamina C é é
cofator, mas não é só isso. Ela é
importante também eh para síntese
endógena de colágeno. E sem a vitamina C
adequada você pode ter resultados ruins
utilizando o colágeno. Então, 5 a 10 g
de colágeno hidrolizado, tipo verisol,
eh mais pelo menos 500 mg de vitamina C,
mais 100 a 200 mg de ácido hialurônico
por dia. Então, qual é o timing? Eu
prefiro que tome junto de manhã ou antes
de dormir.
Aí, aí a conveniência de horário é mais
importante porque aumenta adesão.
Terceira combinação elegante. Se o
paciente está usando, por exemplo, o
canabidiol, por qualquer razão, eu
monitoro mais de perto se ele também usa
taurina.
E a taurina, nesse caso, é bem
interessante porque além de tudo que eu
já falei aqui, ela tem um efeito
hepatoprotetor bem documentado.
E a ideia não é que a taurina vai
neutralizar o risco do CBD alto, mas faz
sentido utilizar os dois juntos, porque
a taurina vai ser um dos elementos que
vai ajudar a prevenir o problema
hepático, né? Então é, faz sentido
fisiológico ter um antioxidante hepático
se você está usando algo que pode
estressar o fígado. Pessoal, eu vou
pedir só um minutinho para vocês que eu
vou rapidamente ao banheiro, tá?
Pronto, pessoal, tô de volta. Tem uma
pergunta da Irma aqui.
Ah, esqueci de pegar o óculos. Pera aí.
O colágeno do caldo de osso é bem
absorvido? Sim. É bem absorvido sim,
viu? Ô Cristina, agora eu não tô
lembrando de nenhum estudo
comparando especificamente o
colágenrolizado
verissol com o colágeno natural do
caldióso,
mas é absorvido sim.
O colágeno que é resultado do mocotó
coado é mais absorvido, certo?
depende da função gásico intestinal da
pessoa.
Qual é a quantidade ideal? Depende do
peso da pessoa e da função gásica
intestinal, tá? Mas eu poderia colocar
que uma poção aí de 200
g aí por dia, seria talvez paraa maioria
das pessoas uma boa quantidade.
Bem, continuando,
então, já falei que para quem tá usando
CBD, a taurina é uma excelente opção
para ajudar a neutralizar o efeito do
CBD, que pode ser ruim no fígado.
Lembrando, CBD carnabidiol.
Agora é importante ter muito cuidado com
o uso do CBD do canamol com múltiplos
suplementos que depende do citocomo
P450,
tá? Então, por exemplo, se o paciente tá
tomando CBD em doses moderadas e também
quer usar curcumina, berberina ou, por
exemplo, a erva de São João, que foi o
que tava me dando branco naquela hora.
Então, erva de São João, tá? é uma
planta que é interessante como
antidepressivo, mas tem um efeito
hepático muito pesado. Então tem que
tomar muito cuidado com a associação da
Eva de São João, o Ipério comum
perfuratum com o CBD,
porque tem essa competição pelo sistema
de detox hepático. Isso pode ser
problemático.
Em relação à time ao longo do dia, a
creatina e a taurina podem ser tomadas
juntas pelas manhã, como eu falei, sem
nenhum problema. o colágio no qualquer
horário, mas muitas pessoas preferem à
noite porque a síntese colágeno ocorre
mais durante o sono. O CBD quando você
utilizar geralmente à noite devido ao
efeito relaxante, mas muita gente usa de
manhã eh por conta de estresse do
trabalho.
E evitem sucralose o máximo que vocês
puderem, tá?
Sucralose é um adoçante problemático,
especialmente quem tá obeso, quem tá com
resistência.
Bem, vamos falar aqui alguns casos na
prática que ilustram, que nós discutimos
hoje, né? Caso um, um caso de um homem
de 58 anos com fadiga crônica,
empresário, com queixo de fadiga
persistente tem 2 anos, tinha feito uso
já de vários recursos e num checkup
completo foi mostrado que tava com a
tiriode normal, a testosterona no
limite, mas não tava tão baixa que
justificasse a fadiga. Vitamina D tava
correta, tava corrigida e a B12 também.
Então é um daqueles casos que não é
óbvio, né, que o as coisas mais comuns
estavam todas adequadas. Então essa
pessoa, esse homem dormia bem, não tinha
pineia do sono. E o que mais chamou
atenção nesse caso é que era um
vegetariano por 15 anos antes de voltar
a comer carne recentemente.
Então a hipótese para esse paciente era
a depressão crônica de nutrientes
específicos da carne, incluindo taurina
e creatina. começou a usar 3 g de
taurina por dia, dividido em três doses,
mais 5 g de creatina de manhã. Em seis
semanas, ele teve uma melhora de 60 a
70% na energia.
Então foi uma mudança substancial que se
manteve ao longo de meses de
acompanhamento. O caso dois, uma mulher
de 67 anos usando varfarina, que é um
anticoagulante porque ela tinha
fibrilação atrial, que é uma alteração
em que o átrio, né, do coração, a câmera
menor do coração, ela fica tendo aquele
disparo contínuo, né? Fica aquela
contração, eh, como se fosse uma
epilepsia do átrio, né? Então ela
começou a usar o CBD por conta própria
para ansiedade,
dose 50 mg por dia. Após 3 semanas
chegou num consultório com hematomas e o
NR tava 5,2, acho tava bem aumentado. O
NR a gente considera até dois. Então
esse 5,2 estava elevado e perigoso.
Então o CBD tinha inibido a
metabolização da vafarina pelo CIP 2CA,
desculpa, o CIP 2 C9.
Isso multiplicou o efeito
anticoagulante. Então foi necessário
suspender o CBD, ajustava a farina,
então em duas semanas teve
estabilização. Esse caso ilustra
perfeitamente porque é importante você
tomar cuidado com as interações
medicamentosas. ela poderia ter tido um
AVC hemorrágico. O caso três é um caso
de uso de sucralose. Uma mulher de 45
anos tentando emagrecer, tava em déficit
calórico documentado, fazendo exercício
regular, com a tirióide, OK? A insulina
de jejum pouco elevada, mas não era
diabética, o peso não baixava, tinha 3
meses. E investigando na dieta dela,
descobri que ela consumia de quatro a
cinco refrigerantes da por dia. Então
era o método dela que ela tinha para
matar vontade de comer doce. Então a
gente introduziu 30 dias sem adoçantes
artificiais.
Falei que podia utilizar STV último
caso. Aí ela perdeu 2,5 kg nesse mês sem
mudar nada na dieta ou no exercício. Por
quê? Porque caiu a insulina. Eh, lembra
que eu falei que a sucralose induz
resistência insulínica? Então, a
insulina de jejum caiu 20%.
Então, veja como a sucralose pode ferrar
o metabolismo do açúcar.
Caso 4, uma mulher 52 anos, com queixa
de pele muito seca, craquelada,
dermatologista já tinha prescrito
hidratantes tópicos.
Eh, iniciamos então colágenizado 10 g
por dia, o tipo verol, né, mais o grama
de vitamina C. Nesse caso, dividiu em
duas doses diárias.
Em três meses teve melhora visível da
hidratação e elasticidade.
Ela mesmo trouxe fossos comparativas.
Então, obviamente ela não rejuveneceu 20
anos, mas a textura da pele melhorou de
forma que ela notou e outros comentários
comentários, né? Outros comentaram,
desculpe.
Bem, vamos aqui responder algumas
perguntas que podem surgir, que é tipo
um
perguntas frequentes sobre o que nós
estamos falando aqui, né? Que vocês
estão fazendo algumas perguntas ao vivo,
mas pode ser que temha algumas perguntas
que vocês não pensaram. Por exemplo, é
possível usar taurina e creatina junto
com remédio de pressão? Sim, é possível.
Na grande maioria dos casos, a taurina
vai ajudar até baixar o remédio
hipertensivo
e a creatina não tem uma interação com
antihipertensivos, tá? Então é
importante você comunicar o médico, mas
sim é possível fazer essa associação
remédio para pressão, taurina e
creatina.
Melhor marca de creatina e já falamos
aqui do selo creapuri e marcas
confiáveis, tá? Essa que é a resposta
sobre marcas de creatina e tem que ser
creatina monoidratada sem aditivos
necessários.
Taurina da sono? Geralmente não, mas
pode dar leve sonolência em algumas
pessoas, especialmente em doses mais
altas se foi tomada de uma vez só.
Então, se der sonolência, divida a dose
ao longo do dia. E pode ser também um um
mecanismo bem interessante para quem tem
dificuldade de dormir, né? Creatina
retém líquido, incha. Sim, como eu
falei, pode ter leve retenção hídrica
intracelular nas primeiras semanas.
Porém, isso é diferente de de inchaço
edema. É uma coisa temporária que dura
duas semanas. A água vai dentro das
células, mas pro espaço extracelular
também. Desculpa, a água vai para dentro
das células e não pro espaço
extracelular. Então, geralmente
estabiliza e não causa desconforto.
Eh, canambidol é totalmente liberado no
Brasil. A situação regulatória é mista e
é complexa. Você tem produtos que a
venda é liberada na farmácia comum com a
receita especial, aquela receita do
chequinho, né? Então aí você pode
comprar na farmácia com a receita de
chequinho, só que os produtos que estão
vendidos em farmácia são mais limitados.
A segunda via de compra é através de
produtos importados com autorização da
Anvisa. E a terceira via de compra é das
ONGs, que tem autorização especial de
comercialização,
eh, que também tem que fazer um cadastro
na Visa também, tá? Então, se tem esses
três jeitos de você comprar o CBD, o que
eu gosto de utilizar é de importação de
empresas confiáveis. Colágeno em cápsula
funciona igual a pó, geralmente vai
depender da dose, mas se for com
quantidades menores não vai funcionar
bem, tá?
Então para atingir a dose que nós
comentamos aqui de 5 a 10 g por dia,
você precisaria tomar várias cápsulas
por dia. E a maioria das pessoas acha
mais prático o pó de sorvido em água ou
suco. OK? Se você conseguir atingir com
cápsulas 5 a 10 g, OK? Posso substituir
todo o açúcar por estéia sem problemas?
A Stévia tem um perfil mais seguro, só
que a gente não tem tantos dados assim
de segurança a longo prazo. O ideal
ainda é você reduzir a dependência geral
de sabor doce. Então usar o stévia só
como ferramenta de transição, mas
cuidado com excesso de stévia, porque a
gente não sabe a longo prazo que pode
dar. Taurina interfere em exame de
laboratório? Não interfere. Pode
continuar usando nas coletas. OK. O que,
o que interfere muito em coleta de exame
é biotina, né, que é uma vitamina do
complexo B. E essa biotina tem que ser
suspensa uma semana antes da coleta de
exames. Quanto tempo demora pra creatina
fazer efeito cognitivo? De quatro a sean
de uso. OK? Ele não é um estimulante de
uso assim, você toma e imediatamente
você vai ter um efeito, como é o caso da
cafeína. A presença da taurina no Red
Bull é para contrabalançar o efeito
estimulante do da cafeína e não porque
ele é um estimulante em si, tá?
Erros comuns, tá? Erro número um, CBD,
pessoa que tá usando o CBD e para de
monitorar enzimas hepáticas, por
exemplo, ou nunca começa a fazer o
monitoramento de enzimas hepáticas. Isso
é um erro eh bem
problemático, porque como eu falei aqui,
tem pessoas aí, a minoria que pode ter
alteração de enzima, mesmo tomando doses
baixas, tá? E os sintomas de
patotoxicidade
eh são silenciosos quando são leves.
Então, é muito importante, é essencial
um monitoramento laboratorial para quem
tá usando o CBD ou extrato de cannabis.
Erro número dois com CBD, automedicar
aumentando dose sem acompanhamento
e aumentar muito rápido a dose quando
não sente efeito rápido.
Teve paciente que estava tomando 50 mg
por dia, não sentiu melhora imediata da
ansiedade em uma semana e decidiu por
conta própria aumentar para 300 de uma
vez. Isso é muito problemático. OK? O
CBD não é igual, tá? Rivotril ou a
Brasolã. Ele não tem efeito agudo
imediato na maioria das pessoas. O
efeito vai ser ao longo de algumas
semanas. O benefício anciolítico vem com
uso regular após várias semanas. Então,
aumentar a dose de maneira desesperada
vai aumentar o risco hepático sem
acelerar o benefício. Erro número três é
misturar o CBD com vafarina ou outros
anticoagulantes sem avisar o médico que
prescreveu o anticoagulante, tá? Então é
o caso que eu cometei aqui do NR de5
que tava com risco sangramento grave
porque tava usando o CBD com a vafarina
e ninguém tava sabendo dessa associação,
tá? Então muito cuidado com isso.
Em relação à taurina, o erro mais comum
é dose baixa demais. Muita gente tá
tomando taurina na faixa de 500 mg por
dia em cápsula e isso não adianta, tá? É
muito pouco pros efeitos metabólicos que
a gente discutiu aqui. Eu mesmo já
cometi esse erro. Então, se você quer os
benefícios do estudo da Science tem que
estar na faixa de 1 a 3 g por dia da
taurina. Então uns 500 mg por dia é
subdose, não adianta, tem que tomar em
pó mesmo, porque assim você consegue
atingir a dose adequada.
Erros com creatina. Primeiro, tem gente
fazendo fase de saturação de 20 g por
dia por uma semana. Isso não é mais
necessário. Estudos mostram que de 3 a 5
g por dia alcança a saturação muscular
em três a 4 semanas. não t necessidade
de sair tacando creatina e pode ter
efeitos colaterais nessa dose alta de 20
g por dia, eh, especialmente gases de
desconforto abdominal, ok? Segundo erro
da creatina é parar de usar porque você
não sentiu nada imediato e porque a
creatina não é um estimulante, não vai
sentir barato, não vai sentir onda de
energia. O benefício é sutil, ele é
acumulativo, você vai ter mais
resistência à fadiga, melhor
recuperação, mais preservação de massa
muscular ao longo do tempo. Então, se
você está esperando sentir algo parecido
com cafeína, não vai sentir, você vai se
frustrar, tá? Então vai abandonar algo
que poderia tá ajudando bastante. Com
sucralose, o erro é achar que trocar
refrigerante normal por diet é
suficiente. Não adianta só cortar as
calorias do açúcar, mas entenda que
existe esse aumento de 20% na
resistência insulínica.
Se você tá ingerindo litros de
refrigerante por dia de maneira
prolongada, você vai est sabotando a sua
sensibilidade insulina. E a solução não
é simplesmente trocar um pelo outro, é
reduzir o consumo de bebidas açucaradas
de modo geral. O colágeno, o erro mais
comum é expectativa e real. A pessoa
toma colágeno por duas semanas e reclama
que não mudou nada, tá? Então temos aí
dois problemas. Primeiro é o tempo,
tempo muito curto. Os benefícios da pele
vão começar a ter comito semanas e fica
mais evidente com 12 semanas. E a
magnitude, o colágeno não vai fazer você
parecer 20 anos mais jovem, vai melhorar
hidratação, elasticidade e textura da
pele de forma perceptível, mas sutil,
tá? Se você tiver essa expectativa de
rejuvenescimento dramático, isso vai te
frustrar, ok?
Então, era isso, pessoal,
que eu queria discutir com vocês hoje.
Temos mais perguntas?
Obrigado, viu, o comentário, Jucioli.
Então, estamos com 1 hora 13 de live. Eu
acho que eu vou encerrar por aqui.
Essa pergunta última veio agora há 8
minutos. Se vocês quiserem fazer a
última pergunta para eu poder encerrar,
eu espero.
Pessoal, eh, eu tô vendo aqui no grupo
do WhatsApp, alguém mandou uma mensagem
7:43
da noite pedindo o link da live, ficou
fixado em cima. Eu acho que tem muita
gente que não entende ainda como é que
funciona esse negócio do link fixado,
né? Uma coisa que me chama muita atenção
isso.
Olha, eu uso mais WhatsApp Web do que o
WhatsApp no celular, mas assim, olhando
aqui, para mim fica bem evidente esse
link fixado.
Então, eu não sei porque tem pessoas que
têm dificuldade com isso. Eu vou até
olhar aqui.
Olha, gente. É porque talvez um celular
fica mais discreto, né? Vai chegar
pessoas que não tão acostumados.
Ou então a pessoa que mandou essa
mensagem não tá no grupo dois, né? Por
isso que eu não conseguiu entrar.
Qual o risco para pacientes renais com
CBD?
Não seria um risco para renais, não.
Seria só para pacientes que têm
problemas hepáticos, tá? Não, renal, que
eu saiba.
Bem, pessoal, muito obrigado pela
participação de vocês. Nós nos vemos nas
lives de terça-feira agora respondendo
as perguntas. Grande abraço, temha
excelente semana aí para vocês.